first
i want to start with congrats on the
movie
is this one of these projects that every
marvel fan should be thanking your kids
for the reason why you're in this movie
because i heard it was like a family
thing just my kid every every choice is
a family thing but uh my kids but taika
thor ragnarok jojo rabbit chris natalie
tessa the whole lot
uh i am a big fan of your work i've told
you this million times i'm so curious
how you get ready for like an emotional
scene or a scene that you know is going
to take a lot out of you so like if
you're filming something on like a
monday that is you know it's going to be
tough how early on are you actually
breaking that scene down thinking about
it can you take me a little bit through
your process uh in honesty i don't
really do that in detail i do the whole
character for bloody weeks and i'm
boring as hell with that i've just i
don't i don't even actually necessarily
read the script itself that much i'll go
through a few times but then i'll
basically go off and and what i want to
be prepared for is that i want to be
able to turn up on the day and the
director says you know what forget
everything let's just make it up and i'm
good and i can just go with it you know
and so that's what i focus on um i don't
focus on i've got to learn my lines i've
got to do that i never focus on that at
all that sort of just comes uh somehow
and in terms of emotional stuff i find
it the worst thing in the world to
prep for that you know because you don't
in life the emotions surprise you right
you never plan on them otherwise they're
fake so just let it surprise you you
know let it happen as it happens if it
happens and if it doesn't it doesn't
happen
um yeah also you never really know how
someone's gonna how someone will react
to a certain anyway i could go on this
for the whole thing one of the things
that i love about taika and and and thor
and what he's done with these two movies
is literally anything can happen in the
movie like he it could just go off on a
weird tangent and i love it it's an
intergalactic tale of uh ridiculousness
so yeah anything can happen can't it
so what were you most what did you i
guess what are you most looking forward
to audiences seeing or what was
something that you saw in this film that
you're like i can't believe this is in
this film there's an awful lot that i
wish was in this film which uh just you
can't have a four hour long film because
there's so much gold that's on the
cutting room floor hilarious stuff and
creepy as hell stuff just but that was
perhaps pushing it to a a realm where
maybe it wouldn't have been able to be
family friendly which we always wanted
it to be um uh but uh it's it's tiger's
sensibility the comedy the tragedy the
ability to have the tigerness and the
and the and and the humor of that and
then but he's got great sincerity as
well you know he's a real artist and and
so it man it's moving that is the bloody
surprising thing with this film is is a
very moving film and then two seconds
later you're laughing your ass off
you are
really scary to look at in the film how
much did you want to leave set and like
go to the starbucks and just walk
through wearing everything that you're
wearing um i was dying to do that and
sometimes also the uh
cool times were so close together that
we actually went should i even bother
taking the makeup off but they said to
me please god don't be driving home
in your makeup because you know we don't
want the first image of gore to be you
know driving your honda civic you know
uh up the street all right
best foot forward please christian so
take it off before you leave the studio
on that note um sir thank you so much
for talking with me i wish you nothing
but the best